[Music]
[Applause]
so fully automated luxury communism like
you say provocative very provocative
title what does it mean
what's it responding to I'll start at
the beginning and hopefully an area
which we can generally find some
agreement on even people that may not
like that c-word and that is that we
live in a time of crisis it's become a
cliche actually to say that we live in a
time of crisis but that doesn't make it
any less true we live in a time of
ecological crisis climate systems
breakdown talk about that later we live
in a moment of a declining economic
model since 2008 permanently stagnate or
even falling living standards even now
falling life expectancy in many places
we have a crisis in mental health the
World Health Organisation says that
depression will be the world's number
one burden of disease by 2030 we live in
an era where we have a crisis of
identity crises of togetherness crises
of the assumptions which more or less
determined human consciousness for the
last couple of centuries whether it's
nation-states whether it's gender roles
whether it's social expectations about
what we're going to do with our lives so
everything is kind of up in the air this
era of crisis now in the book I talk
about four crises in particular which I
think existential challenges to market
capitalism so I'm sure many of you here
and I want to ventriloquist or
criticisms but many of you here will say
guys a Marxist his historical
materialist he's an idiot utopian we
know that capitalism yes it has its ups
and downs but it always comes good in
the end
where's creates new jobs always creates
new innovations even this gentleman's
argument as you're going to see hinges
on the fact that yes life's got
invariably much better over the last two
centuries we're going to agree on that
but what we're going to see over the
next century or over the rest of this
century or the next 80 years I think
really are going to challenge some of
our core assumptions so what are these
crises let's start with the first one
the breakdown of the economic model
which provided prevailed all the way
through its 2008 financial eyes
increasing legal
form of capitalism 2008 we have Lehman
collapse we have a lig nationalized we
are northern rock in this country the
year before
since then what's happened in the UK
between 2008 2015 real wages that's
wages indexed against inflation fall by
about 10 percent in the u.s. not quite
as bad but they kind of just pedal along
more concerning ly food bank rises in
this country nobody heard of food banks
until 2010 now millions of people are
perfectly familiar with them in the
United States the best metric of extreme
poverty is food stamps federal
assistance to eat before 2007 26 million
Americans were using food stamps now
Donald Trump in 2016 for all the talk of
fake news when he said how can Barack
Obama have done so much for the US
economy when 40 million people using
food stamps that was an entirely correct
number and it's a very good response the
idea that the Democrats had run the US
economy in the interests of most
ordinary Americans between 2008 2016
because food stamps still and returns
the average from before the crisis for
younger people homeownership
particularly salient topic in the UK
homeownership is now at its lowest level
since the mid 1980s a remarkable
statistic in the United States
homeownership is now at this lowest
level since the mid 1960s mid 1960s
remarkable I was talking to Vince Cable
earlier and it wasn't meant to be a
moral challenge to him I said you can't
apprehend how angry I am that I've had
to live in 15 places in 15 years just
like I can't apprehend I can't
experience and you get knowledge from
experience apprehension you get
knowledge from reading a book
comprehension you can comprehend
something but to apprehend it something
entirely different
I can't apprehend what it was like to
live through the Second World War Vince
Cable or most establishment politicians
most journalist even most people over 45
who are relatively affluent can't
apprehend the idea of living in 15 place
in 15 years
what does chill mental health where does
your well-being how it destroys
relationships and people but that's one
side
we don't get to person just yet so wages
flat or falling homeownership flat or
falling productivity in the UK what's
productivity output per person per hour
worked in the UK productivity has gone
nowhere for 10 years now all of this is
unprecedented none of this has happened
generally speaking since the invention
of the light bulb so something very
strange is happening and while on many
of these measures the UK is the most
egregious example a number of other
countries have these problems - its
Italy the Baltics particularly around
central Eastern Europe some of the older
people here may be my age and up
probably recall the talk of Japan
experiencing a lost decade after the
early 1990s and then it experienced
another one and it's presently in the
process of experiencing a third one
Italy as well has had a couple of lost
decades and what we're seeing really is
a growing cluster of countries where we
can say Lost Decade Britain is one of
those countries now I would argue I
would submit that's the future of market
capitalism in previously financialized
economies where the sources of growth
were coming from insurance real estate
services and why the economies become
like that what happened and why did the
crisis happen because again some like
Vince Cable would say that the crisis of
2008 was because some people got greedy
like Fred Goodwin they made bad
decisions and now we're all gonna pay
for it well that's not the whole story
absolutely Fred Goodwin is a very bad
person morally degenerate human being as
well as being a business incompetent
however the model that we adopted until
2008 was response to a Christ the late
1970s a fordist capital of declining
profitability with the industrial
production of the fact that West Germany
Japan East Asia were increasingly
competitive in terms of the manufacturer
of consumer durables automobiles etc so
we move into new areas right as we know
all too well ins country with the City
of London and that very temporarily and
that's how you have to understand
history in the long term 30 years is
temporary very temporarily put that
crisis to bed of the late 1970s afford
as capitalism but that re-emerged after
2009 so the idea we can go back
it's the pre 2008 model of corporation
tax coming from the City of London like
you know the gold of ancient Croesus or
the idea that you're going to get the
kind of growth rates that we saw in
Spain based on a housing boom before
2008 not going to happen that's not
going to come back equally we can't
returns the the genius of foolish
capitalism which preceded that for both
political economic also ecological
reasons that's one crisis any current
model which we need to resolve okay I
hope we can agree on some of that even
Vince Cable and I agreed on the earlier
when it turned out secondly climate
change climate systems break down
because climate change isn't just one
thing actually it's a it's a set of
biological weather systems which are all
deeply integrated with one another I was
interviewing a great writer on this ago
with David Wallace wells about a week
ago he's written an exceptional book on
this the uninhabitable earth and he put
it so succinctly he said climate change
isn't just one of the issues that we've
got to address it's not just one of the
books on the shelf
it's the bookshelf so whether you care
about violence against women whether you
care about crime whether you care about
poverty in the global south whether you
care about whether young people can find
opportunities in more advanced economies
like Britain climate change informs the
context for all of these problems so how
bad is climate change you know I saw a
supposedly reputable economists from the
Institute of Economic Affairs and
neoliberal economists there I say
sitting in the Sun with some cherries on
Twitter with as sunny said climate
change is gray very flippant response
okay well let's look at how great
climate changes if we go beyond a world
of two degrees warming which is
increasingly likely it's highly
plausible that will go to all the three
- four - five - six not inevitable but
it's highly plausible and what would
that mean
so three degrees you get the elimination
of the Amazon rainforests becomes it
does it potentially at four degrees you
see methane hydrate coming out of frozen
permafrost and Siberia a bit hard and
this is where things get less certain we
have methane locked into the ocean beds
and that might also be released and
discharged into the atmosphere
science and all that here and here and
there of course the margin of error for
a planet which is five billion years old
is always quite big the margin of error
for all of these things as thousands of
years and in terms of human politics
that's obviously a problem because if
you're saying somebody the climate is
changing and then they look at the
Windigo well it's sunny outside that's
great you know that's not really the the
mental landscape we want to understand
climate change within six degrees
warming what would the world look like
if that runaway sequence of events
transpires six degrees most the planet
would be under water and that which
isn't under water would be desert Lisbon
would be desert that's how far north
things would go and the only parts the
planet actually capable of large-scale
agriculture would be the North and South
Poles but the biggest problem of all is
that there would be so much methane in
the atmosphere anything like with lungs
would struggle to breathe so we have
major problems if we're moving to a
world of six degree it's fortunately for
every in this room that's not gonna
happen in our lifetime probably several
thousand years away hopefully in the
shorter term a world of two degrees
warming what does that what does that
mean and that is highly likely that's
the world that all of our children will
be born into well the UN let's see what
they say they say if we have two degrees
warming by the mid point in this century
that would lead to 200 million climate
refugees and it's not difficult to look
at the current politics of immigration
to think that's a big deal if you're
worried about aging populations a world
of low growth and hundreds of millions
maybe even a billion climate refugees
what do you think of the political
consequences of that I would submit
Donald Trump starts that like a liberal
just the thought so climate change is
big it's bigger than just more hot days
it's bigger than 25 degrees plus in
February it means to continue watching
this video click the link in the top
left or in the description below or
visit a I dot TV for more debates and
talks from the world's leading thinkers
on today's biggest ideas